- When you see her,
when you see him,
that is generations manifested and woven
into the fabric of these games.
Those 81 points, that nine-five-eight,
those 23 Grand Slams...is our alchemy.
Our essence is encrypted into the moments
that stand the test of time.
- [Announcer:] Return to glory.
- The soul of athletics lies within her,
lies within him...
- [Deion Sanders:] Who is SWAC?
- lies within us.
The beauty in the game
is the beauty in our name.
Our sisterhood, our brotherhood,
family ties.
- [LeBron James:] Black history month is every month.
- The fits, the nails, the braids,
the 'fros, the chains.
The lingo is baked in.
- [Jamaal Williams:] It’s all dawg around this mug.
- We’ve rebelled, we’ve shined, we’ve
laughed, and we’ve danced.
Our value cannot strictly
be tied to accolades
because something bigger was achieved.
- [Kevin Garnett:] Anything's possible!
- We've gifted sports with identity, spirit
and culture.
Sports has a purpose...because, you know,
all along, it's always been Black.
Cuz all along, it's always been Black.
- [Lamar Jackson:] Not bad for a running back.
- Cuz all along, it's always been Black.
- [Sam Washington:] Tell 'em to bring me my money.
- Sports history is Black history.